we're now going to learn how to go from
mixed numbers to improper fractions and
vice versa so first a little bit of
terminology what is a mixed number well
you've probably seen someone write let's
say two and a half this is a mixed
number so you're saying why is it a
mixed number well because we're
including a whole number and a fraction
so that's why it's a mixed number it's a
whole number
mixed with a fraction so two and a half
and I think you have a sense of what a
two and a half is it's someplace
halfway between two and three and what's
an improper fraction well an improper
fraction is a fraction where the
numerator is larger than the denominator
so let's give an example of an improper
fraction I'm just going to pick some
random numbers let's say I had 23 over
five this is an improper fraction why
because 23 is larger than five it's that
simple it turns out that you can convert
an improper fraction into a mixed number
or a mixed number into an improper
fraction so let's start with the ladder
let's learn how to do a mixed number
into an improper fraction so first I'll
just show you kind of just the just the
basic systematic way of doing it it'll
always give you the right answer and
then hopefully I'll give you a little
intuition for why it works so if I
wanted to convert two and a half into an
improper fraction or I want to unmix it
you could say all I do is I take the
denominator in the fraction part
multiply it by the whole number and add
the numerator so let's do that I think
if we do enough examples it'll you'll
get you'll get the pattern so two times
two is four plus one is five so let's
write that it's two times two plus one
and that's going to be the new numerator
and it's going to be all of that over
the old denominator so that equals five
halves so two and a half is equal to
five halves
let's do another one let's say I had
four and two thirds this is equal to
it's going to be all over three we keep
the denominator the same and the new
numerator is going to be 3 times 4 plus
2 so it's going to be 3 times 4 and then
you're going to add 2 well that equals 3
times 4 order of operations you always
do multiplication first and and that's
actually the way I taught it how to
convert this anyway 3 times 4 is 12 plus
2 is 14 so that equals 14 over 3 let's
do another one let's say I had 6 + 17 18
I gave myself a hard problem well we
just keep the denominator the same now
the new numerator is going to be 18
times 6 or 6 times 18 + 17 well 6 times
18 let's see that 60 + 48 it's 180 so
that equals 108 + 17 all of that over 18
108 plus 17 is equal to 125 over 18 so 6
+ 17 18 is equal to 125 over 18 let's do
a couple more and I'll leave it in a
couple of minutes I'm going to teach you
how to go the other way how to go from a
improper fraction to a mixed number and
this one I'm going to try to give you a
little bit of intuition for why what I'm
teaching you actually works so let's go
let's say 2 and 1/4 you know if we use
the I guess you can call it a system
that I just showed you that equals 4
times 2 plus 1/4 times 2 plus 1 over 4
well that equals 4 times 2 is 8 plus 1
is 9 9 over 4 now I want to give you an
intuition for why this actually works so
2 and 1/4 so let's actually draw that
see what it looks like so that's let's
let's put this back into kind of the pie
analogy so that's equal to
1 pi 2 PI's and then let's say 1/4 of a
PI right oh honey for 1/4 is like this
1/4 of a PI right 2 and 1/4 and ignore
this this is nothing it's not a decimal
point actually let me erase it so it
doesn't confuse you even more there you
go
ok so go back to the pieces of the pie
so there's 2 and 1/4 pieces of 5 2 and
1/4 pieces of 5 and we want to rewrite
this as just how many fourths of pie are
there total well if we take each of
these pieces a whoops I need to change
the color if we need to take one of each
of these pieces and we divide it into
fourths we can now say how many total
fourths of pie do we have well we have 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 fourths make sense right
2 and 1/4 is the same thing as 9 fourths
and this will work with with any
fraction so let's go the other way let's
figure out how to go from an improper
fraction to a mixed number let's say I
had 23 over 5 so here we go in the
opposite direction
we actually take the denominator we say
how many times does it go into the
numerator and then we figure out its the
remainder so let's say 5 goes into 23
well 5 goes into 23 4 times 4 times 5 is
20 and the remainder is 3 so 23 over 5
we can say that's equal to 4 and then
the remainder 3 over 5 so it's 4 and 3/5
let's review what we just did we just
took the denominator and divide it into
the numerator so 5 goes into 23 4 times
and when what's left over is 3
so 5 goes into 23 4 and 3/5 times or
another way of saying that is 23 over 5
is 4 and 3/5 let's do another example
like that let's say 17 over 8 what does
that equal as a mixed number you can
actually do this in your head but I'll
do it I'll write it out just so you
don't get confused 8 goes into 17 2
times 2 times 2 times 8 is 16 17 minus
16 is 1 remainder 1
so 17 over 8 is equal to 2 that's this 2
and 1/8 right because we have 1/8 left
over let me show you a kind of a visual
way of representing this 2 so it
actually makes sense why how this
conversion is working let's say I had
five halves right so that literally
means I have five halves or if we go
back to the pizza or the pie analogy
let's draw my five halves of pizza so
let's say I have one half of pizza here
and let's say I have another half of
pizza here I just flipped flipped it
over and then so that's 2 so it's one
half to half so that's three halves and
then I have fourth half here right these
are halves of pizza and then I have a
fifth half here right so that's five
halves well if we look at this if we
combine these these two halves this is
equal to one piece I have another piece
and then I have half of a piece right so
that is equal to two and a half I guess
we could say pieces of pie hopefully
that doesn't confuse you too much and if
we wanted to do this kind of the
systematic way we could have said two
goes into five well two goes into five
two times and that too is right here
and then 2 times 2 is 4 5 minus 4 is 1
so the remainder is 1 and that's what we
use here and this and of course we keep
the denominator the same so 5 halves
equals 2 and 1/2 hopefully that gets us
it gives you a sense of how to go from a
mixed number to an improper fraction and
vice versa from an improper fraction to
a mixed number and if you're if you're
still confused let me know and I might
make some more modules have fun with the
exercises